نتواجد في احد الاسواق او المواقع التي تم
قصفها قبل ايام لان القصف متبادل ما بين
الجيش الاوكراني والقوات
الروسيه
والقصف يطال المدنيين سنتحدث عن المحاور
في ذات الوقت الذي الكاميرا تسلط فيه
الضوء على اثار القصف المتبادل هنا في
مدينه دانيسك بالفعل مدينه باقمت ما زالت
تشهد اسخن المعارك نايف رغم تهديد بريجوجن
بالانسحاب وتسليم
النقاط التي سيطر عليها او يعني القواعد
التي وصلت اليها القوات الروسيه قوات
فاجنر في اخر المدينه من الناحيه الغربيه
وما زالت القوات حتى هذه اللحظه تحاول
الدخول من الناحيه الشماليه الغربيه الى
بلده بغداد ومن الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه
من اجل قطع الامدادات العسكريه عن
الاوكرانيه من طريق تشسوفير السريع الذي
يوصل الامدادات الى القوات الاوكرانيه ما
زالت تتمركز القوات الاوكرانيه في الناحيه
الغربيه وما زالت تحافظ وتدافع عن المدينه
بقوه من تلك المناطق بالفعل هناك محاور
عديده في الشرق الاوكراني مثل افديفيكا
ومارينكا شهدت عوده للقوات الاوكرانيه بعد
امدادات عسكريه اضافيه حيث ان مدينه
مارينكا من الناحيه الغربيه تشهد معارك
كبيره نذكر بان الجيش الروسي سيطر على
ثلثي المدينه وتبقى الجزء الغربي وهو
الثلث الاخير هناك عوده في مدينه مارينكا
نحو بلده
محاوله من قبل الجيش الاوكراني للسيطره
على هذه البلده التي يتقدم فيها الجيش
الروسي لكن القوات الروسيه او المصادر
العسكريه من هناك ذكرت بانها صدت هذا
الهجوم كما ان جيش الروسي المتمركز في
الثلثين ثلثي مدينه مارينكا المتاخم
لمدينه افديفيكا نفذ عمليات هجوم على
الناحيه الغربيه من مدينه افديفكا ومعارك
ضاريه في هذا المحور تمكنت جيش الروسي
نايف من توسيع طبعا هي الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه في دخول المدن والسيطره عليها
بدايه بالتطويق ومن ثم الدخول الى الاحياء
في اطراف المدن الوصول الى الوسط ومن ثم
دفع الجيش الاوكراني الى الانسحاب من اخر
المدينه تحاول القوات الروسيه تطويق مدينه
كما كان في مدينه
وتحاول الوصول الى اكمال نصف الهلال حتى
الان لم يكتمل نصف الهلال لكنها وسعت
الطوق خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه
لتوسيع الحصار على القوات الاوكرانيه
وهناك عمليات عسكريه بالالي الثقيله تشهد
كل ليله قصف عنيف حتى الصباح قصف عنيف من
قبل القوات الروسيه ضد القوات الاوكرانيه
المتمركزه والمحصنه جيدا داخل مدينه يبقى
المحور الاهم وهو تصريحات برجوجن
كما اسلفه لم يعلق على ما صرح به
وبكلمات بذيئه سلطت الضوء على نقص الذخيره
وتعمد الدفاع الروسيه بعدم امداد قواته
واضح الاسلحه لافشال عملياته والافشال
تقدمه وقال بان
الدفاع الروسيه تمنع النصر عن روسيا وليس
عن قوات لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس